hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
you know that's a bit weird with the
face cam but you know we're back on four
and again we're gonna be doing some rep
60 duels the reason that the face cam up
is just cuz I just got done with the
stream getting to rep 60 and right as
soon as I got it I just decided screw it
I'll stream and record at the same time
so I managed to just record a couple
games
I fought literally just wardens cuz
that's all season seven is apparently so
yeah I enjoyed the games enjoy that
effect let me know what you guys think
about the new effect do you think it's
worth grinding to loves it on the
comments below if that guy's big for
watch the video peace out
hopefully the Wulin will dethrone the
Knights hopefully not days of old bro
goddess you looking crazy
God looks even cooler I love it
ma my bad bro my bad
want to fill us no bottom all right
let's go
are you you fancy taking your fancy
there's not enough zone in this one
[Music]
that's why I don't like toasts that been
too much because if he gets it free
stuff against me I don't like that I
don't like having confirmed damage on my
ass damn every warden does it did on
that good fly dude good fight though
they played ace oh if you hit a rep 60
Congrats
thanks Johnny I'm betting on the warden
yeah probably yeah you right you're
probably good to do that now I weren't
gonna [ __ ] me up
[Music]
he's clever
oh [ __ ] now that was good that was good
on him
how's it going on dates bro okay I love
the trade oh I should have let it rip
[ __ ] dude no I should have let the zone
rip good fighted I'm [ __ ] up so bad
he has been studying me that's the
problem getting stream snipe everything
else how I play it's not fun that it's
not fun got [ __ ] up
[Music]
[Music]
Ottoman glad afraid a better guard yeah
I'm yeah I see I didn't care about that
I'll go on good stuff
[Music]
that should be GG yeah that's gonna be
GG did they good fight my boyo
oof well everyone thanks max for the
refugee or the rf60 wishes dude thanks
man
thanks as well Johnny man
[Music]
it caught me on that
five hours too early is that there's
like honestly like a really brief window
and sometimes I screwed up I'm still
gonna use that timing as much as stupid
it sounds but don't fight too many
wardens I fight a decent amount but not
a whole lot that really like take the
time with that move LeMond dude
oh he knows I'm going for it he knows
Roe supreme spicy good fight did mr. got
one more you can stream snap buy the
whole foreigner community why did they
decide to give such a [ __ ] guard is
there an actual reason I have no clue of
each it's just cuz they're you throw
some honest and is the best to do a
dashing light into a toast them dashing
light into toast AB no dashing light
heavy faint into toast AB and then a
heavy afterwards is the max punished
oh good crushing counter bro I was I was
waiting for when he'd throw that I was
waiting for that it means I gotta stop
doing I got to stop doing those moves
maybe even ah [ __ ] dude
ah good Fridays oh well clothes stuff if
I meant love this new effect it's crazy
good
it was a season six five four - I
remember it was a pretty recent
tournament reward see if I try to get an
execution it was really hard to get an
execution on the vault lag game brawl
everyone [ __ ] muses that I actually
hate the people that I hate the valium
break through my back it's so cheesy
I was really betting that he wouldn't
cancel that nom [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
dammit dude I can't open him up no good
for I didn't I get started
that valiant breakthrough is such a
crazy weapon
it's a crazy move it's a it's definitely
one of his most popular moves now I like
it just the trending trash except for
number one
I look at YouTube trending the trending
looks trash except for number one what's
on it check in a second
[Music]
hello wolf well [ __ ] me mister threat
detected I I think was cuz I went I
logged on to youtube.com and
accidentally put y uo instead of oh you
what do you mean on that block that
it is such a struggle trying to fight
wardens did holy [ __ ]
same [ __ ] move ever although all the
time I hate it
I really hate valiant breakthrough I'm
gonna block that dude I'm going I'm
sleep nice aw but whatever did not no
problem lucky man you were definitely
good didn't I can't believe I fell off
that [ __ ] dude
I'm annoyed rep 60 yet yeah I hit
throughout 60 Justin what's coming on
Thursday should be submit should be some
event info Jesus Christ bro at the
amount of time this guy's used this move
he's gonna back up and use it [ __ ] oh my
god I forgot some light attack [ __ ] then
that's the one thing I don't like my
it's a light attack or it's um it's a
heavy tank but it's a heavy Perryman say
[ __ ] dude so cheesy shell block that
[ __ ] up Harry I'll spare that good stuff
food
because I'm not used to the timing yet
it's one of the few moves that not I'm
not confident in deflecting yet fighting
machina again back in is warden
[Music]
I see now now that he knows that I'm
trash against it he knows I'm gonna do
isn't it he knows I'm gonna use it or
he's gonna use it consistently
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that bait if I did basically swam it
probably it splat three better or worse
than Platte to Platte threes better it
goes one to five one being the lowest
five being the highest just stay away
and look at that dodge tech do you know
how skill level is determined not at all
honestly
[Music]
I know we let it rip but I'm I was not I
was stupid but I was smart
oh my god I got caught there
Agha Perry should have done that
oh I dude I had the whole fight I [ __ ]
up hard I shouldn't have done that
now I [ __ ] up a little bit I should
have I should have waited I was getting
too cocky with his low health and then I
should have waited for the unblockable
cuz I had a feeling he was gonna faint
that I didn't think that zone was gonna
kill me though I thought I had enough
help for it rigid wall through the
[ __ ] carriage as well as some cheese
ah really I didn't duck really damn I
thought that was I thought that was good
enough what the [ __ ] dude whatever man
I thought that was gonna be good enough
you're playing for honor and I play an
Xbox
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
really
damnit death of those gonna work well I
got caught in the [ __ ] I got caught
in the hay-bale whatever that was next
to me
really
I should've won like right through my
reflex card apparently so I'm pretty
sure I blocked that books whatever
though good fly did you find this
you got me on the I got you on the first
game which got man the second ad I
appreciate him in good fight
[Music]